MA
S USTHISDES MADE THE LAST
IT'SE RT.IIDENT N, MTHE NATIONA
IR LOWERS HAVE REOPED.IN.
BUSINESSES ARE STAG TO
NG FORWARD.
NOWEA
WE CAACKWAR
WE CANLUNGO UIDED POLICIESGEAN S
WHERE WE FOLLOW THE NC COMES TOM
WH WORK TOGETHER AND
LIO EACHVE
THNTRYWARD.
THHAS ONTH'STOT  GAND VOTEAK MA
SCHOOLELTALKED
20.IVE YOUNG PE LIKE  AUDIENCE R
MAKE HEAFFDAODIN
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT.
ND O G OU
WON'HER OWN
SIGUNS OHAND
D Y TALKED ABOUT WANTI WN WAY WP
E CAMP DGOHE
TO ME
SURE THALARGES
CORPORATIONS PAY TIR
SHE O WE CANTHINIKORE
AFFORDAB.E CAN MA R
THIMATE
VOICES HEARD.MAKE ITENOT TEAC
SUPPORBILL THAT WOULD T TO VOTDE
MONEY IN YOU
EVERY DEMOCRAT VOTED
AGAIN.ICH BYITTLE
BIT E
IT REPUBLICANS
TEY EY'RE GOG BETTERHOITO  MAN A
YOUNG PEONTO T.
JUILL
R IDEAS, BUT TWHY INSTEAD, YOUO
WHEN THAT RK, WE S
BRES
LAST
.
PROTECTINGT THAT BO BES
EVERYWHERE
FTOR
INSIDE A TTTBU TY AN G UO
EN'TTHLL T SOMEONE WHO HAS
E HAT,'S'TWE WANT EV
THAT'SD.
USHIMSELF.T YOTI THAT VI
ACHIEV SUCCESS, TERR O GIVE BAC.
I EDEADDERS OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR EVERYB
DYID THAING TO D THE  COMING IN
SERVIC
UC
HINEANLIE INXES TI OR ILDCARE OX
HESCOVERPONTORPOCYOU
ION AN SAFETY
ANPU40OB
HE TOLD SOME VERAT HE MAIL, BUAT
NIA.
DO
.
TG  ITHUYSEE S FLCE.G SCHOOLOF
NGUS PRESIDENAL A
ENE LI
ROL TIME?
ANE SUPPEVUPACWANT TO EMPH
THIS.
AD THAT THN  BASKETBALL.U KNOW..
YOU KN, T'S A GOOD
THAT'S GREAT.
I'M LESSEDCO
IVE
ISSHES A GCE NG, BUT WHOW
NKEORY ALWAYS T EYAT OR SUORA
O C
RS'TY ERGIFLIOCA 6th, TH
EM.
YORE HOOPS
EI HALLY B Y TH QUIETLY SUPPORT.
A O
THT ECTHAT'SSETHINABOUT CHARACT
ACN OFFICE
WH
TOOURE YOU TY E'SOS TH A
MOREORN GETTING D ICAN
AMERICUTOWBUSINESSES AND PUTT ON
THE OUTR THE RICE THEI
THSTEAD US
PROBLEMS?
TH ELECTION'S
VIRGINIA.
INSTEAD OFNG UNITIES TO CUT BAC
STREEN RMATION ABOUTG  A
KEE
TOECD OF STOKINGIM SOO A
A JO KEEP OUR KIDSA.OIOINT WF
GETHAT
R
SCHOOLS TR DSION THEYDO
SO SAFELY  TM.
BOTHER AHE WORLDMOTHERE.
AND  T
PEOP A BETTER LIFE AND THAT'S
THE CHOI.IT'S AHOE WI
NOFINE NOT JT AYTHATOW, I  OMEFW
YOU WERE BORN.M ORN. MONTH
MY OWN DAUGHTEND I THIABNG T T
BU IWITHG.ARA NDAPPENS AND  CH N
LL
FOR THEM.
NET THEY'RE WEHELPING TO DOIT.
TOOF'RAVG
AND ITE.
M HERE TODAY BEC IBELIEVE VIRGI
GHLIEVE YORGE COUNTRD THWORLD TD
WE'RE GOING  MRWLE LIK
EE.OT
KNOW ALE
I NER E'TEN, I'LL MAKE A
AND THEA FORTHNDF NDERSTAN M
USEEHA
PEOPL.U KNOW, WE THOUGHT T
T DONEHE C KIND OF THRUSEOPLE A.
THEY FEEL COOPP.RE WHASA
TV TIME.LKLOOK, I BELIEVE EARIN.
DOREOE VULNERABLE.
JU FT' MEAN, I
LIKE, OHN,TANT TO LOSEMASK
I UN PEKEAHS THIS
RIGHT?METIMES TISHINGTON FEEHA
IK OH,G ABOUT GU?
REAL
I HA
I, I -- S
CLEARLE  ACROS
EAO ANTIRED?
WE CAND
HNOBODY, TERR
IS GOINGOLVED.SUEN
I DIDN'T EVERY AS PRESINTAN, TH.
'S SPECIAL T THE  TRYING TO
MAKE THE ECONOMY MORIN A BIGE
THIS PEOPL A
ETOVE NG T
OB MIGHT NOT -
ATION BEST
EDUCATION.LOT MORE KIDS ER
DYN AMERICA, BE
GOLOREAMERICE!
WHENDEAND WHENE GON S SHOWN THA
THEY WWO Y H
TRACF ACCOMPLISHMETHTO GO
BECAUSER
LY GOING TO ERO  WHEN YE
TERRWHO'
SES.HE W
WIFOR  MAKE THCAFOR TEY. TH
REO RE ID
EFFORT.KNOWI WAS K E I HAVEN' FT
MYT PRESIDTIAL ELEN, NTA
N-AMEROOPER.ERIFE.
ALL T.
BO ES--, SHE M CROW.TI
SHE A CEVEE TI W
E FIRST AFRICAN-  HADME PRENTE .
AND I THT,, IF'S ND, C
IF JON LEWIS WT TIRED, WE
N'IREDOL TN RIGHTSER
SO GO OUD FIGHT ECSEG
TION FOR NERATITOE.
WHERA DEMOCRAT  BALLOIN
NT
GETS DONE.I USED
ETUS
WHATOI TRY BE
ABU.IF YOU IF YOU DOHE
IND,, IF YOU
IF YO
NDD NEIGHBORS ANOTE, IF YOU DO
THL T TERR
TI
RIL BUILD ON OURS IN
URE.
WE'LL KEA
TER AITHN YOU. FLVES.E.
GET TO WORK. WE